The Reincarnation of Gojo kenju secret
plan revealed and more will be discussed
in this one so make sure to stay tuned
for that if you enjoy seeing these
Jujitsu kaai and reviews and want to
keep them coming then channel the
special grade sorcerer within and smash
that like button join the special grade
fan by making this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss future JSU Kaizen
videos and updates you're also helping
us reach our insane goal here on YouTube
of reaching 2 million subscribers by
just clicking one button and I would be
eternally grateful for that and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all last chapter was full
power sukuna just wrecking Hajime as was
expected after his victory over Gojo but
then we saw other characters like
protagonist Yuji coming into play and
yes Yuji is the protagonist although it
definitely doesn't always seem like that
especially recently so I'm hoping now
he'll rise up shown in protagonist style
even as it's hard to picture him doing
much Against full power sukuna but more
on that later this chapter begins by by
switching perspectives though we jump to
a woman with curled hair in a fun outfit
running she's angry at kinjaku for
what's happening at the Cullen games she
asks isn't it too cruel to give them
life once again by turning them into
cursed objects to only take away their
lives again now she's then trapped by a
blob likee curse as she hears Kaku
saying if it's too tasteless I'll add
more flavor if it's too strong I'll add
more of the original you people are like
seasoning and water to me I don't have
any particular feelings towards you so
yeah classic kinjaku not a guy you can
hope to get sympathy from and we sort of
heard a similar sentiment from sukuna
recently as well when he talked about
every human having a unique and fleeting
taste which makes devouring them a
perfect way to pass the time so they are
similar in their lack of sympathy but
Kaku is interesting to keep an eye on
just because he's not as strong and
needs to use more strategy than sukuna
does as a result his planning and
devising is always interesting but he's
definitely not weak and in this case
he's definitely not the prey either the
woman tries to fight back but it's of no
use she goes from drowning from The Blob
to kinjaku fully sealing her head with
it he says even though I don't have
feelings towards you people I sometimes
feel like you guys are too good to waste
he ends her do anyways and reveals that
he's applied cursed objects on
reincarnated ones and a cursed symbol on
awakened Sorcerers so it's easy for him
to track them in their whereabouts heni
appears and is like why are you talking
to her when she's already dead kinjaku
by talking to himself like that did
reveal useful information to us that we
probably needed to know but it's funny
how the mangaka seems to poke fun at
that at the same time in a meta Way by
having another character call it out as
we're getting to though it does make
sense in the context of the story as
well kinjaku starts joking about friends
when confronted by heni kinjaku jokes
about who's qualified to be his friend
and it's a funny list and a short list
so there are only two rules one they
shouldn't bore him and two a more
serious one they should be on the same
level as him reincarnated sorcerer heni
refuses to be kaku's friend because he
says he had enough of friends with long
hair which may be referring to Reggie
star the long-haired leader of the group
hananoki was aligned with whatever
happened though it's funny how he just
hating on long-haired people now such a
random trait to focus on and hate and
then heni finally points out to Kaku you
sure like talking to yourself I guess
that's what happens when you live too
long and Kaku responds because my
friends got fewer and fewer AKA he
doesn't really have anyone else to talk
to so he ends up talking to himself it's
a line that could be seen as pretty
tragic if it wasn't Kaku the one saying
it then Kaku just tells hananoki to hold
on and watches Gojo and sukuna battle he
realizes that sukuna expanded his curse
technique Target to take down Gojo and
he adds got a goodlook face there now
I'm not 100% sure here if he's referring
to H in these spoilers or talking about
what he's seeing in the fight but it is
worth noting that H looks quite a bit
like Gojo in the face in some of these
panels Kaku explains he has left his
curses at Shinjuku to monitor the
situation he also says he'll know if
anyone left Shinjuku based on the total
amount of cursed energy it's sort of
like sensing someone's hockey in one
piece or key in Dragonball he knows the
amount of cursed energy each sorcerer
has and uta's the number two and
especially noticeable nothing crazy here
we knew UTA was a cursed energy Beast
even compared to Gojo kinjaku explains
he also shares sight with the curses he
says the other side has an awakened
physically gifted zenin Maki along with
May's little brother who most likely has
a spatial teleportation type curse
technique which is very cool and of
itself he continues it's risky to just
plan against the sorcerers kinjaku then
had his fill of just talking from the
looks of it and attacks J with his
curses J uses an exploding tooth to
counter you got to appreciate the
uniqueness of Manga and Anime at times
like this anyways his cursed energy
imbued exploding tooth buys him some
time he asks Kaku what's his true
objective and Kaku says he's going to
end the Cullen game by eliminating all
players and with that as binding vow
he'll activate the merging process of
Tangen with all the people in Japan so
it sort of sounds like to me the human
instrumentality project from Evangelion
where people are combined and lose their
individuality either way wiping out
everybody is a pretty good bad guy goal
so Props to the mangaka for that as kjak
was about to finish J he asks don't you
want to make sure if something that you
thought was interesting is true or not
isn't that what living is all about end
quote impr props to J Who until the end
is pretty awesome here and entertaining
he says to Kaku to look at his own
every morning to satisfy his curiosity
he says this with a smile on his face
despite being about to die it's always
inspiring to see epic not to mention
hilarious last moments like this even if
it's not the main characters kenju then
finishes him off pretty easily as he did
with the girl earlier but it seems the
third opponent won't be so easy as we're
about to see we see takaba the failing
comedian arrive to fight against Kaku
and where he fails with humor he makes
up for inability from the looks of it
Kaku attacks him saying he has no
interest in awakened players like him he
thinks yeah of course I just wot at that
nobody Moving on but no our failed
comedian comes out of the crater with no
heavy damage to speak of kjac was
visibly shocked that takaba survived and
makes a very hilarious expression looks
like takaba is fulfilling His Wish
entertaining since Kaku is definitely
not bored right now which I think works
well for both of them takaba says and I
quote you shitty monk you try to kill me
I'm not forgiving you going to get your
butt to jail end quote can jaku feel
something is off with takaba he thinks
what was that it's the first time I felt
anything like this it wasn't that there
was no damage it was like he made it so
there was no damage so surprisingly
kinjaku is now surprised in fighting
someone who can make the damage he
inflicts no damage from the the sound of
it takaba says something I really like
here he says there's a lot of things to
get excited for in the world but the
number one thing to get excited about is
when an Entertainer only there to match
numbers takes the whole show a great
line for him specifically and loving his
character moment right now curious to
see what he'll accomplish here but
they're definitely hyping him up kju
even smiles and agrees you're right but
onto Gojo and his reincarnation AKA
return not only is Gojo a hype character
a case can be made that they need him
right now how can anyone else present
possibly stand a chance against full
power sukuna the mangaka's choices are
pretty much unbelievable power up or the
return of Gojo in some shape or form now
we've seen kenju bring back dead
Sorcerers so we know it's possible
another thing to keep in mind as well is
that sukuna used to be a sorcerer and
came back as the king of curses and if
anyone was as much of an absolute
monster in their human life as sukuna
was that's Gojo with the talk as well of
Tangen moving beyond Being Human and
being tied to a human physical form it's
not crazy to think that sixy Gojo could
come back as someone Beyond human as
well so clearly there's a lot of
precedents that allow for Gojo to come
back one way or another be it as an
evolved life form curse or something
else but let me know what you think is
goo coming back and if not how in the
world could the mangaka possibly write
himself out of this situation where we
got full power sukuna versus Yugi and
friends in good news we got no break
next week so we will see what happens
next soon enough and if you love strong
and hype characters then you don't want
to miss out on my video about all
special grade Sorcerers explained and
rank from weakest to strongest link on
screen right now yes our boy Gojo is in
it like And subscribe to help us reach
our insane goal of 2 million subscribers
on YouTube and I'll see you in the next
one